no it's it's it's very daunting but it's
really not that complicated because
cessna you say that you say that you
literally went on a ten minute written
about how
much you say [ __ ] mess this is not
that complicated
look you can enjoy heaven's feel if
you've like watched
fate zero and ubw that's that's that's
that's the end all because enjoy a lot
of things if you talk to yourself
you you know he's a veteran when he
calls unlimited blade with ubw
it's like it's too long ubw you know you
know what i mean right he comes up so
much in his daily vocabulary
but he has to shorten unlimited
bladeboards
fellow fake fans i tried okay i i i i i
tried my [ __ ] hardest
if i finally i'm not falling for your
trap today
do people just like not watch shows and
then just think okay i'm done i've had
enough of this sharing you know that's
how i felt with faith
well yeah but i mean some people just
get so invested in the characters that
they just want to go further beyond
right who liked sabres so much that we
had this many sabers
why wasn't one saber okay am i am i
mistaken with being happy
i don't know man you should ask his
people okay okay i i like what's wrong
with one saber that's right
why why look at that one saber not
enough okay okay here's the thing right
i didn't get it
until i started playing fake grand order
and then and then
i totally get it because save like i
don't care too much about saber but rin
you know rin's my girl oh oh i know
yeah from from facebook yeah yeah yeah
so so
whenever like there's uh how many rings
are there
i mean there's there's no the fact that
there's not a clear answer this question
is [ __ ] up there's there's not as many
rins as there are sabers
for example for example like getting
ishtar for example i'm like
i i need to get every time there's a
character that kind of resembles rin i'm
like
well i'm not i'm not gonna lie the first
time i saw ishtar i was like oh is that
rin
you know i i hear this [ __ ] and all i
think of like man this sounds like
it's near nearing kingdom hearts level
of [ __ ]
oh no i i i i totally kingdom
because this is we're just talking about
the series we haven't gotten into fate
law
we're not getting into that
i don't like all this like apocrypha and
like
a colleague and stuff you know being
around anime fans here you just hear
these words like apocrypha or whatever i
hear that [ __ ] so much
i don't know what it means i don't know
i don't want to know what it means i
don't know what it means either but i
know it's just a spin-off
so much all i know is that apocrypha and
and khalidillia are spin-offs
but there's spin-offs that also add to
the law it's time
i mean okay
we're not getting into the league okay
so to start off my lecture today on
things that i didn't get before let's go
back to that oh my god
no i feel like two minutes gone say your
piece
okay just watch phase zero watch watch
unlimited blade works and then that's
that's like the mainline timeline so you
can enjoy
heaven's feel and then if you want to
enjoy more of the fake franchise you can
because none of it's technically cannon
even though it is but i'm not going to
get into that
just watch just just watch the main
timeline shows and that's
that's me that's that's it that's it you
say watch the main timeline shows but at
this point we don't know what the main
timeline shows up
i'm convinced people are like fate also
like [ __ ] and ball torture
they want to die the one thing about
faye that i want to say is that i
couldn't
[ __ ] believe when i i asked the same
question
to navi my friend who's like heavenly to
fate about saber i was like why are
there so many sabers
and you know what he said to me he's
like sabre the class will save her the
character
and i mean i went what do you mean
i mean like i mean i mean saber and he's
like yeah which one
i'm like what do you mean what do you
mean which one he's like because there's
saber the class
yeah and then there's the character the
character i know that i know
i know that because like there's she is
the saber class yeah
they say that like the rider right like
the assassins yeah yeah saber class
but then he yeah but then he was like
sable claus every character i'm like
what
saba the one called saber what
which one is it and at that point i was
like
okay i don't think i'll ever be able to
get into this series
or this franchise so bottom line uh when
it comes to visual novels
maybe maybe skip out on facebook i feel
like very committed i'm convinced right
if
if fate didn't exist the world would be
100 more productive
we would have cured every known disease
on the planet
these people are too busy making [ __ ]
timeline charts yeah type moon would
actually be like a cancer institute
right yeah
honestly if we redirected that mental
resource into doing something productive
we would have there would be no poverty
poverty would be ended
but instead we wanted a hundred sabres
that's what we went for it's because we
just want to collect the waifus okay we
just we just want a slightly different
variation of the same character so
so they could they could like sell us to
like roll another like 100 rolls on the
gotcha
and then we can be like yeah i have
another saber i have everything i want
oh wait
they released another saber oh okay
okay i see this is just like that you
know like there's memes where it's like
the [ __ ]
the business meeting with the executives
and they're like what do the people want
they really like it seems like gentlemen
they really enjoy
saber and someone's like saber too saber
two
and it's like three sabers saber two but
it's not
the saber if if saber's so good why
isn't there a saber two
and the the executives like we got your
back super savers
saber black
there's actually like a red saber oh no
i'm done oh yeah red
saber under the same red there's a red
saber and saber of red
those are two different characters at
this point type moon
has to be [ __ ] with us right like i i
guess
i'm i'm ready for them i'm ready for
type moon to just come out and just like
pull and under hideout you just mean
like
yeah all of that has no meaning we just
wanted to [ __ ] with you i'm going insane
listening to god trying to explain this
[ __ ] to me i want to have an episode
where i
hate this i just like spent an hour
explaining fate law to you guys
it's